bienvenidos de nuevo a mi segunda
presentación sobre propiedad de los
logaritmos en esta presentación te voy a
mostrar las otras dos últimas
propiedades de los logaritmos y esta es
para mí la más obvia en cierta manera
aunque si no se te hace muy obvio no te
sientas mal tal vez lo que necesitas es
un poco de introspección y quiero que te
animes a experimentar con estas
propiedades de los logaritmos porque
realmente esta va a ser la única forma
de que los aprendas de verdad recuerda
que el punto de las matemáticas no es
pasar el siguiente examen ni siquiera
sacar 10 en el siguiente examen lo más
importante de las matemáticas es
entender matemáticas de manera que
puedas aplicarla a la vida y no tengas
que volverlas aprender otra vez pero
bueno vayamos a la primera propiedad de
los logaritmos que vamos a ver en esta
ocasión que dice que ha multiplicado al
lugar ismo en base p
deséenme es exactamente igual que el
logaritmo en base b de c elevado a la
anp y te digo que eso es bastante
bastante intuitivo y si no pues vamos a
verlo con un ejemplo así que para esto
no voy a tomar no sé
es que multiplica el logaritmo en base 2
otra vez regresamos a logaritmo en base
2 de d se me ocurre de 8 de 8 está bien
3 que multiplica el lugar en un base 2
de 8 y esto según nuestras propiedades
de los logaritmos esta propiedad que
acabamos de ver lo que pasa es que
dejamos la base igual ponemos el otro
igual pero el 3 va a pasar como
potencias de lo que está dentro del
logaritmo el logaritmo en base 2 de 8
elevado al cubo y si será cierto esto
pues pues vamos a ver y lo primero que
quiero que recordemos es cuánto es el
lugar y tmo en base 2 de 8 o dicho de
otra manera 2 elevado a que potencia me
da 8 así que déjenme escribirlo por aquí
a todo esto lo voy a poner de la
siguiente manera esto va a ser 3 que
multiplica el logaritmo en base 2 de 8
que por cierto esto habíamos dicho que
es 3 esto lo habíamos visto hace tiempo
y entonces me quedaría 3 que multiplica
3 yo lo que quiero ver es que 3 por 3
que es 9 esto es 9 tiene que ser igual
al logaritmo en base 2 de 8 elevado al
cubo
pero cuánto es 8 elevado al cubo bueno
antes de hacer otro elevado al cubo lo
que se me ocurre es pensar en cuánto es
2 elevado a la nave es decir lo que me
tiene que dar y yo sé que 2 elevado a la
8 es 256 2 por 2 4 por 2 8 por 2 16 por
2 32 por 2 64 por 2 128 por 2 256 y eso
es 2 elevado a la 8 de hecho lo que
hemos visto en el vídeo pasado 2 elevado
a la 8 256 y se multiplicó a 256 por 2
pues esto me da 512 es decir 2 elevado a
nueve es lo mismo que 512 por lo tanto
lo que yo quiero ver es que 8 elevado al
cubo sea 512 o dicho otra manera el
logaritmo en base 2 de 512 esto es igual
a 9 y 8 al cubo tiene que ser 512 vamos
a ver si 8 por 8 64 64 por 8 cuánto va a
ser 8 por 4 32 y llevamos 3 8 por 6 48
más 350 y 1 512 perfecto si se cumple
así que acabamos de ver que está
se cumple y si no me crees si crees que
falla en alguno de todos estos
logaritmos puedes ver el vídeo de la
demostración de esta propiedad que
aunque es un nivel un poco más avanzado
va a ser bastante útil y de hecho que
otra forma de verlo 8 elevado al cubo es
lo mismo que 2 elevado al cubo al cubo
porque no es lo mismo que 2 al cubo y
bueno 2 elevado al cubo al cubo por las
propiedades de los exponentes se
multiplican 3 x 39 me queda 2 elevado a
la 9 por la propiedad de los exponentes
que por cierto la manera de probar esta
propiedad de los logaritmos que acabamos
de ver esta que tengo aquí es
exactamente usando esta información que
te acabo de dar esta propiedad de los
exponentes que tenemos aquí pero bueno
vamos a ver la última propiedad de los
logaritmos que tengo que repasar contigo
así que bueno ya tenemos todo esté aquí
déjenme borrar el pizarrón y se me ha
tiempo hasta podemos ver más ejemplos de
todas las propiedades de los logaritmos
pero vamos a esta propiedad que dice a
es el cambio de base claro dice el
logaritmo
base en base de am esto es igual a quien
a logaritmo en base de a logaritmo en
base cda fíjate cómo estoy cambiando la
base entre el logaritmo en base cm en la
base nueva de b y bueno esto es súper
útil para las personas que son adictas a
la calculadora porque por ejemplo
imagínate que estás en un examen y el
profesor te dice en este examen si
puedes utilizar calculadora a ver
díganme cuantos el logaritmo en base 17
de 357 el organismo en base 17 de 357 y
tú agarras tu calculadora bien feliz de
la vida y empiezas a buscar el logaritmo
en base 17 el logaritmo en baches 17 el
logaritmo en base de 17 y no lo
encuentras no todas las calculadoras
tienen el logaritmo en base de 17
entonces tú encuentras estos dos botones
el logo y el l n el log y el l n el log
por cierto es el logaritmo en base 10
y el l n o el logaritmo natural es el
logaritmo en base m
es un número bastante especial y muy
útil en las matemáticas que es 2.71 algo
algo algo algo etcétera y en algunos de
todos los vídeos de khan academy
deberías de buscar los vídeos que hablan
acerca del número de hoy leer y de las
maravillas que hace pero bueno ahorita
no me voy a meter en eso entonces tú
tienes el problema del logaritmo en base
17 de 357 y si hacemos nuestro cambio de
base ya vamos a saber el resultado
porque esto es exactamente lo mismo
nosotros recuerda que tenemos el log es
decir el hogar y no en base 10 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que el log el
logaritmo en base 10 de amp que es 357
en este caso logaritmo envase de 10 de
357 y estoy dividido entre el logaritmo
en base 10 o blog de 17 y bueno nosotros
como somos fanáticos la calculadora
podemos poner esto en la calculadora n
va dar un cierto resultado un gouache
huaychao y después puedo poner logaritmo
en base 17 una calculadora y me va a dar
otro resultado el resultado
y entonces yo puedo dividir estos dos y
ya obtengo mi resultado del logaritmo en
base 17 de 357 estos súper útil cuando
tienes calculadora porque cuando sabes
utilizar una calculadora entonces ya
puedes saber el logaritmo de cualquier
cosa y en cualquier base de hecho esta
propiedad yo la utilizo bastante
actualmente mi trabajo para mí es la
propiedad más útil y que más me sirve el
cambio de base logaritmo en base b de a
es igual a logaritmo en base se
cambiamos de base de amd entre logaritmo
base de b y seguramente quieres ver la
demostración de esto pero no te
preocupes en próximos vídeos
voy a demostrar cada una de estas
propiedades pero bueno seguramente esta
es la que más va a utilizar en tu vida y
si quiero que lo sepas los logaritmos
son útiles así que vamos a terminar
viendo muchos ejemplos en muchos
ejercicios en este vídeo ejercicios que
tienen que ver con las propiedades de
los logaritmos vamos a ver un ejercicio
en donde utilicemos todas las
propiedades o muchas propiedades de los
logaritmos me voy a tomar el logaritmo
en base 2 de
a la raíz cuadrada de 32 la raíz
cuadrada de 32 entre la raíz cuadrada de
8 de 22 entre 8 entre la raíz cuadrada
de 8 y si podemos con esta entonces me
voy a tomar el logaritmo envase todos de
la raíz cuadrada de 32 entre la raíz
cuadrada de 8 y bueno cómo puedo
representar este mismo logaritmo
simplificándolo con las propiedades de
los logaritmos vamos a ver qué sale y
espero que no esté tan desordenado todo
lo que voy a hacer lo voy a hacer de
manera vertical y que me queda el
logaritmo en base 2 de y date cuenta que
esto es lo mismo que 32 entre la raíz de
8 elevado a la potencia un medio y por
la primera propiedad que vimos en este
vídeo es decir la tercera propiedad de
los logaritmos decía que esto es lo
mismo que un medio la potencia baja
multiplicando el logaritmo un medio que
multiplica al logaritmo de 32 entre la
raíz de 8
pero ahora podemos usar otra de las
propiedades de los logaritmos porque
aquí tengo una división 32 entre la raíz
de 8 logaritmo de 32 entre la raíz de 8
y por lo tanto puedo ver esto como una
diferencia del organismos utilizando la
segunda propiedad de los logaritmos que
vimos esto es lo mismo que un medio de
paréntesis este que es un paréntesis un
medio que multiplica el logaritmo en
base 2 no olvidemos la base logaritmo en
base dos de 32 menos el logaritmo en
base 2 de la raíz de orc el logaritmo en
base 2 de la raíz de 8 cuando se están
dividiendo pueden pasar como una
diferencia de logaritmos y bueno ahora
tengo 8 a la un medio entonces esto es
lo mismo que un medio que multiplica el
logaritmo en base dos de 32 menos un
medio porque estos 8 elevado a un medio
recuerda que las potencias bajan
multiplican a logaritmo un medio del
logaritmo en base 2 de 8 pero bueno lo
primero pues es distribuir este un medio
me queda un medio que multiplica primero
a logaritmo en base 2 de 32 y después un
medio que multiplica a 1
me queda un medio no espera me queda un
cuarto un medio por los medios un cuarto
menos un cuarto que multiplica al lugar
y en base dos de ocho y esto es lo mismo
que cinco medios menos logaritmo base 2
de 8 es 3 tres cuartos cinco medios
menos tres cuartos que es lo mismo que
diez cuartos menos tres cuartos que
siete cuartos espero no haber cometido
errores aritméticos y que tú te hayas
quedado con la idea nos vemos pronto